こんばんは　8時になりましたニュースのお時間です
昨夜未明、静岡市在住の
自称映像クリエイター はじめしゃちょーの自宅に
年齢不詳の20代の男が突然彼の家に訪れ
「雇ってほしい」と言いながら
彼の家の前にいられる事件が発生しました
静岡市在住のはじめしゃちょーの自宅には近年、
中学生や小学生が訪れ
迷惑しているというニュースはよく聞きますが
就職活動で彼の自宅に人が訪れたのは
県内初の事件になります
警察は犯人の身元の特定及び
近隣への聞き込みを開始しておりません
また事件当時現場には
自宅に訪れていたはじめしゃちょー氏の
従業員3名で対応された模様です
容疑者は震えた声で「雇ってほしい」と連呼しており
当人含む従業員3名恐怖で怯えていた模様です
容疑者）いや、雇ってほしい気持ちは本当ですけど
たなっち）あぁ…
たなっち）すごい過呼吸みたいになってますよ
はじめ）どうした？
やふへゐ）いや多分はじめ君のファンで
一緒に働きたいんっすね
はじめ）いやー無理っすねー
やふへゐ）待ってでもはじめ君に出たら
やふへゐ）またあれなんすよ
行ったら会えるみたいになりますよ
たなっち）うん
はじめ）確かに僕は行かないようにしよう
たなっち）ん？今なんかｗあの俺上で
「わかった、雇いましょう」って聞こえたから
降りて来たんすよｗ
はじめ）いやでもまぁ普通に考えると
やふへゐ）いかんことしてますからね
はじめ）そもそもうちに来ること
時点でもう社会的な
だいちぃ）うーん確かに確かに
はじめ）面を考えると厳しいんで
やふへゐ）ただし
たなっち）面接をした上で不採用
現場と実況が繋がっております
やふへゐリポーター）
はいこちら事件現場からの中継です
こちらが事件のあった江田 元さんのお宅です
現場では一晩経った今も依然として騒然としており
近隣住民が外へ出る様子はみられません
また犯人の行方もつかめておらず
警察は厳戒な態勢で捜査を進めておりません
以上現場からちゅうk、、
通行人）うぉ〜ぃ
また近隣の住人からも心配の声が上がっています
近隣の住人B）何かきゅうしょく(就職)だ
近隣の住人A）就職ってお前、え、
だってしゅーつ(スーツ)で来たってことでしょ
近隣の住人A）ふはははｗｗｗｗｗｗ
現在現場付近では警備の強化を進めており
調査員を含める計8000人態勢で現場の調査
及び犯人の行方を追っております
ﾌﾌｯ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】